Okay.
I was browsing The David Pakman Show sub Reddit
this morning, which of course you can find
at David Pakman dot com slash.
Read it.
We have surpassed twenty thousand subscribers
to the David Pakman show.
Read it.
One of the largest independent progressive
media subbrand.
It's on Reddit, if you can believe that.
A user posted an article called Trump has
a Point about the polls from Politico.
And the gist of this article is that there
were some state polls in 2016 that were wrong
and there were some state polls in 2016 that
said Hillary Clinton was going to win by a
small margin and Trump won by a small margin.
And certainly that's true.
And, you know, my my goal on this show has
been not to inaccurately assail polling more
than it deserves, but also not to hold polling
up as any kind of immutable and unchanging
metric that tells us exactly what's going
to happen in November, in 2016.
The polls were widely accurate.
The national polls said Hillary Clinton was
going to win by three and she won by a little
more than two.
That that means they were right.
They were.
The results were within the margin of error
in most states.
They were right.
It is true that when states are really, really
close, sometimes state polling that is done
even five days before the election may not
reflect who is going to win that state.
And certainly Michigan, Wisconsin and some
other states are examples of that.
So what we should take away from this is not
that polling is widely untrustworthy when
we are talking about high, highly rated pollsters.
It's understanding that there is a margin
of error and that things can change.
Also in the last few days before an election.
So if it tells us anything, it's that no matter
what state you're voting in, you need to vote.
And that no matter what the polls say, you
need to vote.
That's the message.
And there's no you know, there's no big revelation
about the the particularly inaccurate polling
in 2016.
The polls were mostly right nationally and
at the state level.
The polls did not account for some momentum
and swings in Trump's direction close to the
end of the campaign.
And there were states where Hillary was leading
in the polls and she ultimately lost.
What that tells us is the polls give us a
sense of what's going on, but we need to absolutely
crush turnout to ensure that Trump doesn't
end up winning some of these states by 11000
votes, again, like he did in Michigan.
That's the takeaway.
Another post on the Subrata is about YouTube
botto play up, pointing out that no matter
how many of my clips people watch on YouTube,
they still get last week, tonight recommended
instead of more David Pakman show clips.
This is an ongoing issue with YouTube's algorithm.
We actually have a new a really great study
from Mark Ledwidge, who has been studying
this stuff about exactly how the YouTube algorithm
has hurt our channel.
It's an excellent piece that Mark did, which
I'll present to you when we have some time.
It's not the most urgent thing, but maybe
next week I'll have a little time to talk
to you about it.
So, yeah, YouTube, if you watch corporate
media will recommend you corporate media.
If you watch alternative independent media
like The David Pakman Show.
YouTube will still mostly recommend you.
Corporate media.
So the best thing to do is you subscribe to
our channel on YouTube.
You hit the bell to tell YouTube.
You actually want to be notified.
You want to see all of our posts in your feed
and maybe even via email if you want, but
don't feel obligated to do that.
That's really the best way to ensure that
you are not missing our content.
Lastly, a user named Bacon and caffeine is
criticizing my pronunciation of the state
whose abbreviation is F.L. saying David.
It's Florida, not LA.
So I'm from Massachusetts.
And here, unless you're from certain neighborhoods
in Boston, you you do pronounce it Florida.
When I say Florida, I'm sort of joking.
That's the the New York accent way of pronouncing
Florida.
You know, I. I am Jewish and I do have relatives
who have moved from from New York to Florida.
And their pronunciation is Florida.
I understand.
But both are certainly valid pronunciations.
Thank you.
OK.
Join the discussion at David.
Ackmann, dot com slash, read it.